Dyson is a company known for its bold
designs and unique reinvention of common
household products they include the
world's first bagless vacuum cleaner
high-velocity haired hand dryers
bladeless fans air purifiers and the
supersonic hairdryer Dyson is also
branching into retail CBS this morning
got the first look at the company's
flagship demos store in New York City
which opens tomorrow Sir James Dyson is
the founder and chief engineer at Dyson
welcome back to studio 57 so while
retail is having issues in all kinds of
different ways why open a store well it
is a bit counterculture but we like
people to get their hands on things
I mean we're putting more and more
technology into products which need
explaining and people need to be able to
tell the difference I mean for example
our hand power our battery powered
vacuum cleaners you wouldn't believe
there is powerful as mains machines but
they are but people need to see that you
know we're trying to break conventions
who think battery machines are useless
and the batteries fade ours don't so we
want people to be able to see that and
and realize that there's a very new way
of vacuuming you don't have to have the
cord and the heavy vacuum cleaner what's
at the heart of your technology
especially in the vacuum cleaners which
I like many years ago we started
developing a new type of electric motor
new technology electric motors so we've
made them much smaller much faster and
much more efficient and that's really
the heart of it all we've also developed
batteries but that's another story but
the motor that's in our hair dryer for
example is about a quarter of the size a
normal hair dryer mater and a quarter of
the weight so we put it in the handle
and that's why it's so light so I'm
trying to get you to buy one because
discovered it's very very good so if you
get the basic technology right and you
create breakthroughs then you can design
a really interesting product around it
but the technology is the most important
thing yeah so now you've done the vacuum
cleaner you do the fans you're opening
up a store and then there's a rumor
you're getting into the car business
what qualifies you sir James to get in
the car business well I hate diesel
exhaust pollution and about 20 years ago
I developed something that collected
diesel exhaust pollution but governments
are going around saying hey Green is
clean and it's green
so it's a good thing and that people who
use diesel engines didn't want to fit it
because it was the problem of disposing
the dust so I've had this burning desire
to have a form of transport other than
an IC engine other than something that
belches out nasty stuff petrol entrance
send out nasty stuff and now you're
doing an engineering school - yes more
people like you coming back well there's
a tremendous shortage of Engineers and
you may need more and more to develop
software artificial intelligence more
this kind of thing so you need about
five times the number of engineers now
that you needed before and I went to see
the Minister of Education Boris his
brother in fact I was Johnson Boris
Johnson yeah to complain that weren't
enough in engineers and he said well
start your own University it took me
about three seconds to say yes and he's
created in you act to allow people like
me to start universities so to be within
the company they'll work in the company
they'll work on new inventions they'll
take products into production and
they'll have two days a week doing
academic studies so there are no student
holidays it's a full year it'll take
them four years I pay for their
education I pay them I pay them a salary
and yeah they've got a job and at the
end of it they've got a job if they want
to leave they can leave whatever there's
no time
why the way they're wonderful I mean
they're quite shocked all our existing
engineers were there questioning and
that challenge two of them seventeen
it's a great sort of influx of what's at
the heart of the innovations and
creativity is it just looking at
everything and asking questions about it
I mean well it is not very hard
a lot of things don't work very well or
they're all good or something you don't
like about it and so we set about
getting rid of that and you know other
people aren't bothering to do that so
there's tremendous scope for someone
like me does work differently don't you
think you what do you think you take
things apart and try to put them back
together or you're looking how can I
make it better
there is a process oh yes oh now I want
yes there is and I learnt that but yes
you look at something and you see it
wasn't working why isn't it working
what's it doing wrong what's it missing
and then you set about improving it well
it can happen another way that you
develop a technology and then you work
out where you can use it where it'll
make a real difference
and that's actually how we got into hair
drives apart from the fact the hair
dries actually they're not very good and
damage your hair and they're very heavy
and balance is awful although it's
really trying to solve you'll be
appearing at the brick-and-mortar store
yes you're doing blow outs at the store
I heard is it oh yeah absolute best and
how it's good vacuum
well James Dyson what a pleasure always
to have you here and learn about all
your innovations thank you so much thank
you very much thank you